Okay, but how stable are your kids
if the relationship is so fucked up
that you're thinking about leaving?
You don't wanna leave,
you're leaving and coming back and leaving,
coming back.
That is not a stable home for children.
You are like,
not fully being honest with yourself about
the situation.
You're like,
oh, you know,
what does stable for your children mean?
What do you want your children's lives to look like?
Do you know what I mean?
If the most important thing to you
is that your children
see both of their parents every day
and sleep in the same exact bed at home every day,
and that's what stable is,
sure, that's stable.
But if stable means they have parents that they can
lean on for emotional support and guidance through life,
and they're
both of their parents are very present because
they're not distracted with this abusive relationship,
to me that's stability.
You know, cause we could go on vacation.
What if we had this amazing life
where we're going on vacations all the time,
we're sleeping everywhere,
Mommy's traveling,
daddy's traveling.
You know, we have this fun,
amazing life
that's still stable and beautiful,
it's just lacking the abuse.